le sommeil de la belle au bois dormant a
été troublée aujourd'hui par le bruit de
la parade et de nombreuses équipes de
télévision six mois tout juste avant
l'ouverture d'eurodisney à
marne-la-vallée son château qui l'une
des principales attractions du parc de
loisirs a été inauguré en début d'après
midi il y avait beaucoup de monde des
petits fours et au milieu c'est bingo
rni et amenait djoudi j'ai le plaisir de
la veille lors du jeu rude aux trois ans
on nous avait promis du spectacle on n'a
pas été déçu la parade les confettis les
ballons à la démesure d'une organisation
toutes américaines pensent et 2000
invités triés sur le volet et un bon
millier de journalistes venus du monde
entier à chouchouter promotion du parc
oblige
vous savez il faut créer un suspense et
le suspense est que à partir
d'aujourd'hui le parquet les fermer
quelques donc vous même une fois le
revoir closerie 80 neige
le spectacle était aussi dans la rue un
peu surréaliste la visite du plus grand
chantier d'europe après eurotunnel qui
laisse la presse un peu crottés que
voulez vous ce sont les risques du
métier
les trois casses member pardon les
employés disney se rode peu à peu au
sourire mehdi l'american cheese
côté attractions le royaume de la magie
est aussi celui de l'artifice les
rochers sont crevés déception le château
de la belle au bois dormant et en béton
et même les enfants ne se laissent pas
abuser par mickey et compagnie bakou
c'est à dire est bien des merciers gaza
il est le monoprix ne s'est pas
seulement des attractions
c'est aussi un type de société et
particulièrement ce fait un peu peur
challandes images ça fait peur moi pas
de soucis côté militaire le centre
d'information disney ouvert en décembre
a déjà accueilli cent mille curieux et
la vente des tickets d'entrée marche
fort avec des réservations pour l'an
nick et peut dormir sur ses deux
oreilles